né sont pas leaders comment le monde
comme vous pouvez le voir mais c'est ce
qui est difficile
ce n'est pas le cas mais je pourrais
tremblay pourrait voilà c'était typique
en fait je stresse et du coup vous voyez
c'est beau sourire qui peuvent nous
aider tous ceux qui sont prêts à m'aider
lever la main il ya un gros potentiel
dans la salle du coup vous êtes tous
bienveillant finalement vous vous mettez
à nos places vous comprenez je suis en
difficulté et malgré tout vous voulez
m'aider c'est ça aujourd'hui qui fait
que vous pouvez devenir leader alors il
ya deux types de respect au sein des
entreprises
la première c'est celle avec un boss
c'est la hiérarchie en gros c'est
l'entreprise qui est dit potel boss et 6
en 1 qui bossent pas eh ben tu peut
sanctionner tout le monde
c'est ce genre de typique où vous êtes
manager dans mon cas à mcdonald's et
al'inverse en bas vous avez leader et
donc votre potentiel à tous tous vous
êtes capables de m'aider ou en tout cas
vous êtes bienveillant ça va être une
hiérarchie qui est horizontale beaucoup
de mots pas grand chose mais dans les
faits finalement c'est vous qui êtes
capable d'aider les autres vous allez
les aider tout simplement à sentir mieux
vous allez aussi faire en sorte de
partager votre savoir
alors pour passer de l'un à l'autre il
faut déjà comprendre finalement que vous
êtes sûrs d'eux attentes différentes
quand vous êtes un manager quand vous
êtes un boss vous êtes là pour
l'entreprise vous devez gérer les
équipes planifiez vous assurer que le
respect des procédures et bien établi
que la suite alimentaire elle a ainsi
que le respect des personnes
lappartient humiliante en gros et puis
vous pouvez devenir leader c'est la
capacité que vous avez finalement à
fédérer une équipe autour de vous qu'est
ce que vous faites pour ça est ce que
vous êtes souriant comme vous l'avez
fait avec moi si vous avez envie de les
aider
est ce que vous leur apprenez à
surmonter leurs difficultés c'est ça
finalement pour moi être un leader et
aujourd'hui j'avoue partager quelques
outils si vous aussi vous avez envie de
venir cette personne ou d'aller encore
plus loin
la première c'est bien comprendre que du
coup les humains ne sont pas d'émules
nous avons tous des bagage émotionnel
comme vous pouvez le voir et c'est ce
qui nous freine au fur et à mesure ce
sont tous les sujets que nous avons
abordé précédemment finalement qu'est ce
qui fait quand vous arrivez au boulot
bah vous n'avez pas forcément envie
est ce que c'est une situation
personnelle est-ce que vous avez un
problème au travail c'est tout ça et
vous en tant que leader je vous demander
finalement d'aider les personnes qui
vous entourent à les enlever
commencez déjà par pas être en colère
c'est facile n'est-ce pas ne pas être en
colère
comment on fait quand un incident arrive
demandez-vous déjà quelle est la cause
de cet incident et pourquoi ça vous
impact finalement dans mon cas par
exemple en restauration rapide
quand un équipier mme fait tomber une
boisson que j'ai déjà une centaine 200
étudiants femmes et comme vous qui
réclament tous leurs plateaux en gros ça
peut vous énerver mais à ce moment là
vous avez deux réactions possibles soit
c'est un ancien est juste il va
justifier mes diamants fait regarde
c'est pas tomber à cause de moi c'est la
gravité pas ma faute finalement et d'un
autre côté vous avez un nouveau qui va
être stressé la nouvelle recrue celle
qui vient d'arriver qui a envie de bien
faire et qu'ils y aux non j'allais faire
une connerie là qu'est ce qui va se
passer en fait j'aime faire brasser
devant tout le monde
ou c'est que je vais prendre le
nécessaire pour nettoyer etc c'est cette
situation que vous trouvez du jour au
lendemain qui va falloir vous en tant
que leader amené à corriger tout de
suite dès qu'un incident arrive au lieu
de hurler sur la personne de l'humilier
devant tout le monde et finalement de la
perdre parce que non seulement elle va
perdre du temps à trouver ce qu'il faut
qu'on ait foyer mais en plus quand elle
va revenir le stresser elle vous faire
tomber d'autres boissons
elle va tromper dans les commandes les
clients vont revenir et ainsi de suite
et ainsi de suite
dites-vous plus tôt ok la pression est
tombée est-ce que c'est grave finalement
c'est un coach c'est pas le mien et puis
ça coûte 30 centimes au coq alors du
coup c'est pas grave tu va me prendre là
la serpillière qui au bout tu va me
prendre à un panneau se glissant qui est
là-bas tout nettoyer ça en deux secondes
en deux minutes du moins et puis tu vas
revenir et on va reprendre et ça va bien
se passer
et surtout ça ça va bien se passer
tolérer l'erreur autour de vous c'est
pas si grave finalement
la plupart du temps d'ailleurs tendance
à péter les plombs pour pas grand chose
alors la première chose que je voudrais
moi c'est contrôler votre colère et fait
en sorte de leur enlever leurs bagages
est ce que c'est si grave
est-ce que vous aussi vous avez pas
connu cette situation finalement ou
quand vous arrivez vous avez pas les
compétences mais il ya quelqu'un qui va
vous montrer en fait vous allez
apprendre tout ça et vous aller de plus
en plus
à l'aise de plus en plus souriant et
quand quelqu'un fera l'erreur et bien
soyez tolérants à nouveau alors
malheureusement ne pas être en colère
c'est pas forcément ce qui est plus
facile
j'entends que du coup quand vous
commencez à vous connaître vous êtes
tous jeunes suppose c'est un peu
difficile
la première chose qu'on fait quand
quelque chose n'a fait que c'est ce
médecin la défensive c'est super mais
deux visages comment ça hurlait plus
fort que l'autre pour essayer de se
cacher mais on va prendre de situation
complètement différente vous montrer
qu'il ya d'autres solutions
imaginez-vous du coup en voiture pour
tous ceux qui ont permis les autres
attendait un peu vous êtes dans un suv
un truc plutôt confortable vous êtes en
vacances finalement et puis il ya une
dynamique qui vient et qui met sa vie a
traversé le truc bien pénible mais
finalement c est en vacances alors nous
en 6 ou 10 ou au bourget y'a pas
forcément grand building
si vous êtes à new york vous allez
prendre le temps de les regarder ce qui
se passe autour de vous vais la garder
peut-être les passants les deux trois
trucs qu'on a pas ici et vous allez-vous
calme et finalement c'est peut-être vous
télé ou faire klaxonner parce que vous
avez mis trop de temps à regarder le
paysage et que la mamie elle est passée
là vous allez être bienveillant c'est
pas très grave finalement sa venue est
le maître du temps mais maintenant on va
prendre un autre contexte
vous êtes jeune vous venez d'arriver
dans votre entreprise c'est votre
première réunion et vous êtes déjà un
peu stressé et playa cette même mamie
qui met sa vie sauf que vous êtes en
retard
le premier réflexe c'est quoi cette
klaxonner c'est l'insulté lui dire de
aller chercher son petit chariot et puis
d'aller plus vite
non il va falloir relativiser pourquoi
vous êtes en colère finalement est ce
que c'est la mamie ou est ce que c'est
parce que vous êtes en retard et vous
avez pas vous faire humilier tente monde
en arrivant à la réunion
posez vous les bonnes questions
demandez-vous toujours si je suis en
colère
est ce que c'est la personne est ce que
c'est la situation est-ce que c'est leur
qu'est ce qui se passe finalement est-ce
que j'ai des problèmes moi aussi et
ainsi vous avez pour trouver des
solutions alors pas son coup un surcoût
klaxonner crier parce que vous voulez
mais quand vous rentrez demandez-vous
bien est ce que cette mamie c'est
quelqu'un est-ce que c'est elle qui m'a
fait tout ça et du coup trouver une
solution pour la prochaine fois centre
ont des solutions tous les jours que
vous allez prendre les bons réflexes à
chaque fois que vous avez un problème
demandez vous qu'est ce que moi j'ai
fait pour que ça se reproduise pas et
c'est ainsi comme ça ou du moins c'est
ainsi comme ça désolé pour le français
mais c'est comme ça en gros que vous
allez pouvoir trouver des solutions vous
construire à venir estime une meilleure
confiance en un temps souvent et qui me
disent
écoute j'ai pas confiance je sais pas
quoi faire bah en fait il ya des
solutions
commencez par chaque fois que vous
rencontrez un obstacle vous dire qu'est
ce que moi j'ai fait pour cet obstacle
il s'enlève ça c'est le plus important
ensuite vous allez avant la présomption
d'innocence
alors qu'est ce que c'est à chaque fois
qu'on va vous faire du mal à chaque fois
qu'on va vous dire un truc qui vous
déplaît vous mettez pas sur la défensive
dites-vous plus tôt s'il l'a fait il l'a
pas fait exprès est-ce qu'il avait déjà
les bonnes compétences
est ce qu'ils savaient de quoi vous
parliez fait lui répéter avec vos mots
sinon en prenez lui tout simplement
est-ce qu'il avait le matériel aussi et
ainsi de suite et ainsi de suite
posez vous les bonnes questions pourquoi
il a fait ça je vous donner un autre
exemple typique
vous avez peut-être tous déjà été dans
ce cas là alors pas dans mon cas mais
dans le cas du client il ya quatre ans
un soir un client départ qui me dit
ouais c'est inadmissible l'étape sont
sales le personnel dit pas bonjour vous
sauriez pas c'est quoi ce mcdo bla bla
bla et au final un blabla j'ai pas dit
ça au manager mais du coup c'est plus
vous avez tendance des fois en tant que
client à laisser vos émotions prendre le
sud
ce que je comprends tout à fait alors du
coup le manager à ce moment là qu'est ce
qu'il fait mais lieu sur la défensive
en fait moi je suis souriant moi je dis
bonjour moi je regarde en fait ce qui se
passe et puis à ce moment là bas
justement je regarde ce qui se passe
tout se passe plutôt bien les commandes
sont servis en deux minutes le personnel
alors tous ne sont pas souriant mais
celui qui donne les commandes en tout
cas s'en occupe
et puis je vais voir en salle qu'est ce
qui se passe en salle finalement il ya
une poubelle sur huit pieds sales
il ya trois tables sur les 40 comparé
débarrasser par le client et puis il ya
deux trois tâches de ketchup en effet
alors je continue parce que oui c'est
pas dramatique mais du coup je peux
comprendre que le client soit satisfait
pays et je vais aux toilettes et
j'entends pleurer et je me dis mais
qu'est ce qui se passe à leurs stocks
et puis je me demande si tout va bien
l'employé sors mon employé sort en
larmes je le dis mais qu'est ce qui a
bien pu se passer finalement alors elle
se pose et je lui dit t'inquiète pas en
fait on va en parler
qu'est ce qui t'a arriver à ce moment là
et elle me répond simplement bas je
venais d'apprendre que le chant sainte
je me suis fait mettre à la porte et en
fait par là si je perds mon boulot
demain chez paou sais que je vais loger
ça vous met un coup vous passez de la
haine contre le client qui vendent ou
médecin a finalement comprendre ce que
l'employée avec
alors à ce moment là je me suis posée et
puis j'ai réfléchi
finalement après en son innocence ça
sert à ça quand quelque chose se passe
avant que m soit défensive demandé je
vous déjà pourquoi pourquoi le sémillant
finalement il s'est mis à hurler pour
deux tables de salle une poubelle qui va
pas et puis pourquoi sur moi en fait pas
parce que je suis responsable
sage le club c'est ma part de
responsabilité je la prend par contre sa
colère après ce qui avait pallié à autre
chose et ce qui l'a pas déprimé que sa
famille est-ce qu'il a pas perdu son job
ses enfants un foyer peu importe on a
tous des problèmes qui peuvent justifier
ce genre d'excès de colère du coup c'est
la première fois que je me mettais à
place d'un client et puis je me mets à
la place de l'employé finalement quand
vous arrivez vous avez envie de bien
faire vous n'êtes pas forcément envie de
dire écoute là je suis pas bien je vais
pas travailler surtout si vous êtes un
peu d'essais et du couple à ce moment là
quand quelqu'un vous parle mal sanafir
tendance à remonter vos émotions et puis
vous avez peut-être pas faire votre
travail en effet moi je me reste que
c'est important
est ce que c'est important si la
poubelle et les salles enfin si la
poubelle n'est pas changé si la table
est sale
si votre manager vous tirer dessus il
yad'autres finalement priorité alors moi
je peux comprendre ce qu'elle a fait
c'est le deuxième point que je vous
demande et après votre colère demandez
vous toujours si la personne qui a fait
ça l'a fait contre vous ou si a pas
quelque chose à l'extérieur
vient ensuite une autre règle un petit
voyage en pose cette fois l'histoire de
métier cause de cliquer pour ceux qui
sont déjà les en thaïlande
voici un temple bouddhiste sont des
temples sacrés et là bas dans la culture
vous devez apprendre et assez vite
seulement que la tête est relié à tous
qui est sens propre alors que les pieds
tout ce qui est sale et un pur quand
vous combinez les deux du coup si vous
arrivez à vos chaussures dans le temple
forcément il va y avoir un problème
alors vous allez avoir des écriteaux
enlevez vos chaussures mais ce que vous
allez le faire parce que c'est interdit
ou parce que tout simplement vous avez
pas envie d'impacter sur leur culture
est ce que vous allez vous dire en fait
moi si je prends mes chaussures qu'un
chalifoux timbre jaillit sa religion
tellement je néglige la personne est-ce
que c'est celle-là poulets aux lettres
est ce que c'est cette personne voulait
incarner en tout cas il existe donc de
règles la règle d'or c'est ça qu'on vous
dit quand vous êtes depuis que sept
petits en tout cas ne fait pas aux
autres ce qu'on ne voulait pas qu'on
vous fasse
c'est bien c'est la même culture c'est
peut-être la même éducation du cours
valeur se rencontrent donc là pas de
problème mais si on parle de la règle de
platine qui dit
ne faites pas aux autres ce que vous ne
voulez pas qu'on vous fasse ce que ça
vous parle ça vous pouvez levez la main
si on à qui ça parle fait pas aux autres
si vous ne voulez pas qu'on vous fasse
et combien ils appliquent maintenant il
ya moins d'enthousiasmé je vais vous
demander après la présomption
d'innocence et que vous avez un conflit
finalement demandé vous qu'est ce qui
est important pour l'autre parce que oui
c'est important pour moi peut-être vous
êtes en coloc pas mal d'entre vous même
et puis un jour vous rentrez pierre
inverti traîne sur la table une offre
par exemple une colère noire
en fait tu es toujours là tu éteins ta
console tu fais rien tu fait pas le
ménage moitié fait les courses et là
vous déballe terré vous déblatérez la
sica dolata bien envers mon gars tu vas
prendre
et puis finalement à la fin c'est vous
un jour qu'oublier le vert parce que
vous avez vous faire larguer vous avez
pris au petit verre de coca pour vous
réconforter et qu'il ya l'autre qui
vient et puis ils vont mais la même
couche à la fête à leur retour de bâton
c'est cadeau demandez-vous toujours
finalement donc pourquoi il a fait ça et
puis si c'est important pour lui la
prochaine fois mont vernon je vais
nettoyer c'est pas grave ça va reprendre
deux secondes ça m'évitera une chasse
mais c'est plus fait le pas ce que vous
avez envie d'aider la personne c'est ça
qui est important
soyez bien veillant au tout début quand
j'étais encore en stress beaucoup
d'entre vous levez la main on dire bah
on va t'aider
y'a pas de soucis mais en fait c'est ça
qu'il faut voir au quotidien c'est pas
parce que là aujourd'hui un speaker qui
vous êtes 200 vous êtes un groupe
forcément il faut un peu se lier au
groupe ben en fait fait là parce que
vous avez envie demandez vous pourquoi
il agit comme ça et qu'est ce que moi je
peux faire pour ça et mieux et aussi
quelles sont ces valeurs qu est ce qui
est important pour lui je vais peut-être
pas l'aider mais au moins je vais pas le
frustrer chacun sa part de
responsabilité au final
et puis voilà le meilleur outil le
feedback vous m'avez entendu un petit
peu parlé avant le feedback c'est un
retour que vous faites
il faut être positif en gros on dit tout
le temps ce qui va mal mais très
rarement ce qui va bien et puis dire ça
va bien pour dire ça va bien c'est pas
très efficace alors moi je vais vous
demander à partir d'aujourd'hui si en
tout cas vous avez envie d'être de vrais
leaders d'être précis quand vous dirai à
l'arc
vous pouvez pas juste ça pis vous tiré
au hasard on voit où la fée celle vin en
général c'est pas très précis alors qu à
l inverse
ça va être on va dire l'exemple plutôt
dieu écoute c'est cool tu as fait le
ménage ou alors c'est bien tu as une
bonne note
c'est bien j'ai mon repas c'était beau
c'était pas ce à quoi et à l'envers si
vous êtes précis avec l' art et du coup
viser la cible vous allez atteindre la
personne directement quand je suis
rentré sur un avion un conflit hier la
jolie fanny triton verdot la poussière a
été fait et en fait moi quand je rentre
je suis à l'aise donc merci pour ça ça
peut être aussi bain
al'inverse quand cette fois vous n'êtes
pas bien écouté là ça va mieux
tout à l'heure je sais que tu as fait un
effort parce que du coup d'habitude
c'est plutôt un grand sur la propreté et
la du coup bah j'ai pu souffler donc
merci pour ça voyez c'est en fait en
disant précisément parce que l'hôte a
fait de bien pour vous que vous allez
avoir de l'impact
si vous dit juste c'est bien évidemment
il reproduira pas al'inverse préciser
pourquoi c'est bien il va en général
tout faire pour satisfaire un nouveau
et voici la fin quand vous avez un
conflit du coup et maintenant vous êtes
capable du mans vous avez des pistes
pour gérer votre colère qui vous êtes
capable de vous mettre à sa place
et puis aussi de savoir quels sont ses
valeurs en général on en vient à ça au
début ça gueule un peu et puis avec le
temps finalement on se calme on apprend
à relativiser et puis ans massa place si
on prend l'exemple tout à l'heure par
exemple de la personne qui fait tomber
son verre
qu'est ce que je vais lui dire ok t'as
fait tomber inverse pas grave
dans tous les cas pas la prochaine fois
je veux juste un mois y est plus réactif
ve a tout de suite cherché le nécessaire
passez un coup oui on en parle plus
quand vous êtes avec votre colloque
quand il aura fini de vous brassez dit
lui ben oui j'entends
du coup j'ai pas fais mon verre la
prochaine fois je vais nettoyer a pas de
problème par contre est-ce que tu veux
juste me le dire plus gentiment jamais
faire larguer et du coup pas un pet que
me faire rouler dessus c'était pas la
solution
voyez c'est tout c'est genre de truc il
faut que vous fassiez au fur et à mesure
demandez-vous toujours est ce que je me
suis posée est ce que je me suis mis à
sa place est-ce que j'ai énoncé ma
volonté à moi est plutôt mes désirs est
ce qu'il annonce était désiré ce que je
me plie essaye tout cette bienveillance
finalement qu'un jour tous ensemble on
fêtera ce succès et moi du coup je vous
invite là tout de suite
ao féliciter parce qu'en fait c'est
grâce à vous au début quand j'ai vu tous
ces visages souriants ses mains se lever
pour mais dès que j'ai pu prendre la
confiance et faire ma conférence
alors merci à tous